torge will es wissen will dsds in den
charts hinter sich lassen wird das
schaffen ihr könnt ihm helfen
links unten in der beschreibung wie er
seinen titel superstar kostenlos kaufen
könnt und jetzt im interview
hallo hallo christa reese die lage es
gibt ein
der klassiker ja alles gut alles
wunderbar selber auch alles bestens wir
sie haben samstag knapp ja etwas noch
nicht ganz 24 stunden nachdem deine
fantastische dinge superstar raus
gekommen ist
und die ist jetzt auf wo genau um die
lage zu spezifizieren die lage zu
checken also im moment ist sie bei
itunes auf platz 3 man mag es kaum
glauben ich kann selber com/blog bei
amazon auf zwei und bei musicload auf 1
und ich habe gestern gelesen ich habe
heute morgen gelesen dass es gestern die
meistverkaufte single in deutschland war
nein doch gott also wir sind gespannt
die chancen stehen also nicht schlecht
weil das ist das ziel der sds nicht nach
vorne in den charts zu lassen
genau das ist dass sie richtig und hast
du denn damit gerechnet dass es so gut
läuft
nein natürlich nicht also wir haben
gesagt versuchen das einfach mal
irgendwie und gucken was dann passiert
aber man konnte das schon nach ein paar
stunden sehen dass das irgendwie viele
leute total gut führt also das nicht
selber und die aktion irgendwie auch und
deswegen habe ich da absolut nicht mit
gerechnet dass es so einschlägt schon am
ersten tag vor allem und ok da würde ich
jetzt sagen
hand aufs herz das ist doch eine total
auf karierte aktion da ist doch jedes
detail geplant als die wir hatten wir
haben natürlich ein paar sachen geplant
aber wir hatten tatsächlich nur zwei
wochen zeit und das ganze ding auch zu
ziehen weil das war am anfang da hatte
ich keine zeit wenig zu machen und dann
haben wir andere probleme noch gehabt
und dann hat sich das wird die erste
herausgestellt dass es wirklich losgeht
und dann mussten wir ganz schnell den
song aufnehmen in dresden und alles
irgendwie uns überlegen
deswegen war das eigentlich noch fast
ein zufall dass es noch so wirklich
zustande gekommen ist
ok man aber den plan hattet ihr schon
länger und am stand
je länger die dichte stand eigentlich
schon länger aber es war eigentlich so
mal daneben
die fassen dass wir sagen aus den
gründen gehst dann leider irgendwie doch
nicht okay und wir sind jetzt die
reaktion äußerst gut also ich kann es
selber nicht glauben also erst mal fern
ist total geil dass der song selber
total gut ankommt das freut mich
natürlich richtig gut aber auch dass die
leute sagen wir finden diese aktion
einfach total lustig einfach mal dem
großen rtl riesen damals irgendwie eins
auszuwischen
wenn es denn klappt aber ich glaube so
ein bisschen ich denke mal so ein
bisschen was wären die schon mitbekommen
haben weil ich meinen herr bohlen bittet
der wird sicher auch die charts angucken
und die download-charts des tages also
ich glaube so ein bisschen zittern die
schulden ja man muss ja auch sehen dass
läuft wirklich wahnsinnig gut
gestern abend gab er das finale von the
voice kids das war der große start für
tim bendzko neue tim bendzko es neue
single am seidenen faden
und die hat es gerade mal mit massiver
unterstützung von prosiebensat 1 auf die
elf geschafft da sieht man es fällt den
alten medien immer schwerer bei
irgendwie fuß zu fassen
und ich glaube jetzt jetzt merken diese
langsam das wirklich dass man youtube
bei ernst nehmen sollte und umso kleiner
wäre es natürlich mit denen nicht nur
schock versetzen sondern sag mal den
deutschen noch ein bisschen tiefer
das wird dann auch sagen wir gehen nicht
auf platz vier oder fünf sondern dass
wir sagen leute wie sting jetzt noch mal
wohl doch noch mal runter und dann laden
wir wirklich auf 1 und dann würde ich
gern mal das gesicht von herrn bohlen
sehen und von anderen leuten hatte den
eindruck dass unter den fans auch ein
bisschen die motivation ist die singen
zu kaufen um den eins auszuwischen
ja ich denke schon also ich glaube dass
das ist ja ganz gut man wird aus zwei
eier salz weil sich irgendwie
angetrieben einmal vielleicht weil viele
leute sagen ich finde das lied einfach
google wollen zu haben und andererseits
für viele etwas sagen wir wollen rtl als
auch zwischen also von daher ist es eine
sehr gute mischung die da zusammenkommt
und ich hoffe natürlich dass ja gestern
erst der erste tag macht dass die media
jetzt auch langsam darauf aufmerksam
werden und das dann sich auch vielleicht
noch mal leute das lied unterland die
mich vielleicht gar nicht kennen oder
sandra gar nicht kennen die einfach nur
sagen schön immer gegen rtl das konnte
man gut
und dazu gibt's ja noch was
es gibt eine aktion für ich glaube du
kannst genauer sagen für eine impf seite
und da kriegt man da kriegt man
natürlich um alle möglichen musiktitel
zu kaufen aber ich glaube es passt bei
dir am besten da geht man musicload
gutschein und ich glaube deswegen bist
du da auch auf was jetzt eins oder zwei
musiker auf 1
deswegen müssen auch ein der gag er so
link unten in die video beschreibung der
gag ist das mädel das dafür steht dass
er der kopf der kampagne ist das ist
jazz von bosch keine aufforderung ist
deinen titel mit dem gutschein zu kaufen
es ist richtig lustig also ich hab das
essen ich habe sie erst gerne kante
haben daher andere beschrieben dass sie
das ist und es ist super gau also du
musst einfach nur dieses christin fünf
fragen die musst du dann einfach mit
beantworten aber richtig oder falsch ist
eigentlich okay und dann gibst du deine
e-mail einem bett in codes zugeschickt
und dann kannst du das ding kostenlos
runterladen dem song und wenn du auch
express geht bei mir sind wird musst du
dich da nicht mal anmelden also das geht
auch super einfach also das sollten
unbedingt alle machen also wie gesagt
und nun in der beschreibung
das ist total der absolute gag und eben
dass diese wäre campern jeder als neben
spitze bestimmt noch mal anrufen
wobei das war ja noch das konnte ja
niemand ahnen
dazu kommt wird dich unterstützen es
gibt eine wand eger noch und also die
ganze community steht hinter dir
weil und deswegen natürlich auch die
gesehen der weise hoffen und drücke
natürlich die daumen weil das für uns
alle ein riesen zeichen ist wenn du es
schaffen würde dsds nicht nach vorne
kommen zu lassen er ich bedanke mich
doch ganz letztlich weiß ich hab schon
von waikiki gehört die da starb am
sonntag ein video nochmal für mich
machen um alle aufzurufen
das ist natürlich richtig geil und würde
mich natürlich freuen wenn das video
oder diese ganze videos immer noch
weiter verschickt werden und dass man
sich nicht darauf ausruhen gesagt wir
haben es schon geschafft immer weiter
und weiter und weiter und dann geht es
richtig ab weil das wichtigste ist du
kannst es nur schaffen wenn du jetzt
eine woche lang immer vorne bist genau
also es nützt nichts wenn ich jetzt
einfach vorne bin oder zwei tage weil
ich heute abend wenn es schon bitte das
dsds-finale sein und da wird dann
sicherlich könnte ich mir vorstellen die
dame dann weit vorne landen es ist
wichtig dass wir dann gleich sonntag
wieder mutterland wieder laden
nochmal das dass sie gar keine chance
haben sich der oben irgendwo festsetzen
dass ich nicht aus diesem top ten
rausfliege das ist ganz ganz wichtig da
drücken wir die daumen und vielleicht
das war ja der apfel da gibt's dann in
ein paar wochen ein duett mit ihr oder
dass ich würde sofort machen
ich habe auch gehört dass diese eine
krank ist da das ist so auf der kippe
steht ob sie pop auftritt also ich würde
mich sonst auch zur verfügung stellen um
damit er mit der anderen zu sehen
beatrice zu sehen bei rtl kürzlich auch
gerne machen wenn rtl sich das anschauen
wie man hier in köln sagt für nix fies
das ist prima ich danke vielmals wir
alle drücken wir die daumen und wir
posten und machen und tun noch eine
ganze menge und dann schauen wir mal wer
am ende alt aussieht auf jeden fall
du spielst vorne eine rolle mit das ist
schon so sicher wie das amen in der
kirche und mal gucken wer dann sehr das
quäntchen mehr power hat danke schön
viel interessanter